Today, the National People's
Congress, the new Chinese
foreign minister, came out swinging
if the United States
does not hit the brake,
but continue
to speed down the wrong path.
No amount of guardrails
can prevent derailing.
And there will surely be conflict
and confrontation
Well, that was Ching
Jiang speaking earlier
these sharp
warnings, the latest sign
of how
low relations have sunk
between the United States and China.
So tonight we ask,
how close are we to all out
conflict between the world's
two largest superpowers?
Mark Stewart back with us this hour.
He's in Tokyo on assignment.
And Kylie Atwood is at the US
State Department.
Mark, let's start with you.
The key issues.
What are they
that the foreign minister was
speaking about
Well, the foreign minister
really has been touching
about a lot of issues.
First of all, he mentioned
even the recent balloon
shoot down in the United States.
He talked about the U.S.
involvement
with Taiwan and its support for Taiwan.
He also accused the US of trying
to orchestrate a NATO's style alliance
in Asia and made suggestions
that Asia could be
the backdrop of a conflict very similar
to that of Ukraine.
Certainly a long list of grievances,
if you will,
but not necessarily unexpected.
And Gong at one point
was the Chinese diplomat
to the United Nations and to the US, and
has basically made this shift
from someone who has been careful
and thoughtful
to taking on more aggressive tones
like that of Beijing. Strong wording,
very stringent wording
and a very tense tone.
He is trying to establish himself as now
a key player, very Beijing centric.
And at the same time, as you mentioned,
we have the National People's
Congress, beginning
with Xi Jinping beginning a new term.
So they, too, also
want to have a very strong tone.
Look, there is certainly tension
in this area.
We have seen militaries across the region
really beef up
and include Japan, where I am now.
But for the moment,
the war of words
seems to be the dominant weapon,
at least at this point, Becky.
For I let you go.
It's a war of words.
We've been hearing one side of this
very loudly from the US who are bent on
putting into place stronger
economic measures against Beijing.
We are seeing
that return by Beijing at this point.
What do they put on the table
Well, it's interesting
because as you know,
the Chinese
economy has really been suffering,
especially because of zero
COVID lockdown.
The testing and the quarantines
all had a big financial toll,
especially on local governments.
So in a way,
Beijing needs help from the West,
including the United States.
However, in
just the last few hours, we heard Xi
Jinping make comments
saying that the West
and the US
have really held back
China's growth and development
and has made overtures
to heads of Chinese companies to be side
by side, step by step
with the Chinese communist government.
But at the end of the day,
China does need help from the outside,
and that's the United States and the West
Fascinating.
All right, Mark, stand by, Kylie.
Any response at
this point from the US side?
No, not yet.
We're still waiting.
State Department
has a briefing later today.
But I do think that the context
is important here.
Obviously,
these comments made
during the National People's Congress.
As Mark was saying there.
And so therefore, you have a foreign
minister who's new to the job,
who is likely, you know, making comments
that make him seem, you know,
a really tough incoming leader.
In this role.
And US officials will have to just wait
and see what
that looks like
in terms of his actual engagements
with U.S.
officials.
It's worth
noting that
he and the secretary of state
were both in India
for the foreign ministers
meetings of the G-20
just in recent weeks.
And they didn't have a meeting.
Now, obviously,
the secretary of state
did have a meeting with the other top
diplomat, Wang Yi of China,
just a few weeks ago.
But that was a contentious meeting
because that was around the time,
of course, of that Chinese spy balloon.
It was after the US shot that down,
which is obviously
creating a lot of tension
between the two countries.
And then, of course,
accelerating those tensions.
Are the warnings
from the Biden administration
that China is considering
lethal assistance to Russia
to be used in the war in Ukraine.
So we've got a number of issues
that are really challenging
the two countries
relationship right now
and it looks a lot different than it did
at the outlook
at the beginning of this year
when it looks like U.S.
officials and Beijing officials
were potentially going
to try and kind of engage
with one another.
Well, now that has been halted.
And I asked yesterday
the State Department
spokesperson
if there was any plans
for the secretary of state
to go ahead
with his rescheduled trip to Beijing
that was canceled
because of that balloon.
And they really had no good answer.
There's
clearly not a date on the calendar
for that trip right now.
And one thing that Ned Price said
was that the United States wishes
that they had more
and in some ways
deeper lines of communication with the
Chinese right now,
That's interesting.
Let's just hear some more from what
the new foreign minister had to say.
This is on Sino-Russian
relations
commercial.
When Russia and China work together,
there is an impetus
for the multi polarization of the world
and the democratization
of international relations.
And a
global strategic balance and stability
will be more guaranteed.
The more turbulent the world is,
the more Sino-Russian relations
must move steadily forward.
And colleague,
you alluded to the allegations,
the frustration that Beijing has
with these allegations from the US about
that.
There's no evidence for this as of yet,
but the sense that China may be
getting set to send
lethal weapons to Russia
How is the US preparing
for the potential further
alignment of two of its strongest
adversaries at this point?
Yeah, it's a great
question and really what we've seen them
try and do
is get other countries on the side
of the United States in opposition
to this possible move by China.
We've seen the Secretary of State
talk to a lot of European allies
to make sure
that they too would oppose
that lethal assistance.
We've actually heard
in recent weeks
from some of those European leaders
mirroring what the Biden administration,
German Chancellor Schultz
saying just last week
that they have warned
the Chinese against going ahead
with this lethal assistance to Ukraine.
So while the Biden administration
has repeatedly said that they don't think
that we are entering a period that would
mirror a new Cold War,
because the US and Chinese
economies are so integrated,
which was not the case
with the US
and Russia during the Cold War.
It is a moment where it seems
that there is a big
polarization happening,
which is just the result of
many forces at play.
But the Ukraine war
appears to be accelerating
that bipolar nature of U.S.
and China competition.